so you are look you could do worse than
the Kardashian sisters right because
they've built themselves this huge
business empire what are you going to do
with their sit with her sisters well
that game will be helping end of the
year sort of a bit of an industry trade
secret as to how will differentiate that
experience it will be something that we
see is entirely complementary to Kim's
own game which is obviously going strong
and this week in addition to announcing
a partnership with Kendall and Kylie we
announced the first ever competition
yesterday to actually get a chance to
meet Kim if you are lucky enough and
successful enough playing her game in
the next 10 days okay so if you made it
to the a-list right then you get to meet
the a-lister that's how it works Niccolo
so you've also signed a deal with katy
perry i know that game is supposed to
come out sometime in the summer so have
you kind of found like the secret sauce
is the secret sauce to go to hollywood
in order to keep your games going well
we think we've pioneered a new genre in
gaming we are effectively part of I
think the future of Hollywood you know
DVD sales and record sales are sort of
going away and what glue offers people
like Katy Perry Kendall and Kylie Kim
Kardashian is a one-stop shop for you
know concept development design
publishing distribution and we're
working with you know this talent these
celebrities directly there's no
intermediaries and we're signing very
long term deals these are all five year
exclusive partnerships so we believe
that katy perry will be bigger in five
years and today you know she's got 175
million social followers today Kendall
and Kylie about 75 million social
followers Kim I think high 70 so
together we've got what we call a
celebrity gaming platform yeah with over
300 million social followers following
these games by the under 2015 so Niccolo
Kim's husband of course is Kanye West
and he recently made some comments that
he's interested in getting into video
gaming so are you gonna sign a deal with
him we don't we don't disclose we're
gonna do next but i did say on the
earnings call in early februari that by
the end of 2016
I expected to have over 400 million in
direct social followers of blue games
via celebrity partnerships so should
definitely watch this space in the
coming months we'll make we'll make
another announcement okay well he said
he's a big chunk of that I mean it would
be shame on you Michael if you didn't
sign Kanye West if he was gonna go in
gaming right well you know we are of
course friendly with with Kanye and we
are with the entire kardashian-jenner
family but we're looking of course
beyond sports I mean beyond music and
reality into the sports space as well
and there's a lot more genres within
music so in the fullness of time I think
you'll see us continue to sign talent up
directly and you'll see us continue to
build out what I consider the the
leading celebrity gaming platform in the
world for this these types of
transactions and partnerships okay so
the big issue or the big you know the
big issue for for for those who follow
this gaming space Niccolo as I look down
the list right guys bring up the list of
companies who are crushing in a mobile
gaming right King digital's number one
but I look at some of these games like
my kids right now Niccolo they love
clash of clans I can't get them off that
game right now but I could have said
that six months ago about plants vs
zombies which they now play not at all
so you know kids these days they're
picking up the games and their drop of
them just like that and so you get these
what one-hit wonders how do you make
sure you can get beyond that you can get
them to stick more well it's a good good
question and there's really two things
glue is doing one we are very far from a
one-hit wonder we put out about a dozen
or more games per year in four different
categories we have eight franchises of
which kim is one of our three biggest
games but there's also titles like deer
hunter those titles like racing rivals
we're bringing out a new terminator game
this summer we're bringing out a new
double-oh-seven james bond game the
first one's ever made for mobile by the
way and so we're a diversified portfolio
and the social followings of these
celebrities were working with I believe
we're going to help us create long-term
annuities I wouldn't sign up five year
deals if I didn't think a Kim game or
multiple games with her multiple
games with Katy Perry multiple games of
Kendall and Kylie could really go the
distance and prove that we're building
frankly you know multi-year annuities
very very far in terms of how we're
viewing the business much more like an
an annuity platform then certainly
anything near a single s-curve then one
shot product right